à
non
les chasseurs alliés au cours de la
seconde guerre mondiale les avions de
chasse ont dicté le déroulement des
opérations aériennes le nombre et la
qualité de leurs chasseurs ont donné aux
alliés une suprématie aérienne total
celle ci a permis alors bombardier
d'atteindre leurs cibles
elle a également offert aux forces
terrestres a lié la liberté dans pays
les tactiques elle voulait
les chasseurs américains anglais ou
soviétique rencontres art écrasèrent les
forces de l' axe qui se dressèrent face
à eux ils en portaient également des
bombes et des roquettes et un rosaire
les matchs en ce sens thérèse de lax
d'un véritable déluge de feu venu du
ciel
les chasseurs allié au père est
également depuis des porte-avions sur
tous les théâtres d'opérations majeures
du cosim le développement des chasseurs
a10 cuminal avec le célèbre p 51 mustang
qui vont et escorté les bompard tiennent
loin à l'intérieur de l'allemagne puis
rentrer à basse altitude en mitraillant
au passage les aérodromes des
transalpins
là
finalement les à lyon 2000 et les
dations de lax en matière de qualité de
conception de quantités produites et
donc combattant avec des chasseurs qui
étaient de grands avions de combat sans
doute les meilleurs selon les standards
de l'époque
un ses capacités les alliés plus tard
dans la guerre à l'état ajouté un
chasseur en réaction certes un peu
primitif tandis que deux autres jets
plus bonnaire était alors d'entrer en
service lorsque la guerre s'achevait
tout au long de la guerre le principal
chasseur de la royal air force
britannique fut le très réputé spitfire
conçu par reginald mitchell en 1949 le
spitfire marque un peu des deux mille
six cents kilos et sur moteurs rolls
royce berlin 2030 chevaux l'entrée des
vitesses de près de 600 km heure en 1945
le march 21 peser plus du double et son
moteur fif on lui donnait le double de
puissance
sa vitesse atteignait alors plus de 720
km heure
une des versions les plus rares fut le
marque 8 h f optimisé pour la haute
altitude avec un moteur merlin à double
étage un cockpit pressurisée des ailes
aux bouts pointus une envergure de 13 m
tous les marques 8 avait la roulette
deux cabots table et à l'exception des
premiers exemplaires d habitude dérive
large au sommet pointu 140 marque 8
furent construits pour permettre à leur
rêve de pouvoir intercepter lieu coeur
86 r les autres montbarnier volant à
haute altitude
développé par la luftwaffe
par opposition le spitfire marque 8 l
aefe avait un moteur merlas optimisé
pour développer sa puissance maximum à
basse altitude et des halles ronnie du
ans derrière total de 10 m
c'est elle raccourcit augmenter la
vitesse de roulis car l'expérience du
combat dans le désert avait montré que
ce qui importait le plus c'était
l'agilité abbas un type
la guerre dans le désert avait également
démontré l'importance d'équiper les
moteurs des filtres à sable sur les
moteurs est ici des spitfire marc zahnd
s'est équipée de berlin 45000 470
chevaux d'école pour une mission chacun
porte une paire de banques de 250 lits
et furent sans doute les plus lents de
tous les spitfire car même après avoir
largué leurs beaux et pourrait atteindre
seulement 560 km heure un total de 2400
47 marque 5 ses fils aux trous
1940 les skins ailleurs mark 1 et mark
ii avec une structure plus légère moins
de blindage et 8 mitrailleuses calibre
0,303 faisait face à la puissance de la
luftwaffe dit
en 1942 les marques 5 rapporté des
fibres de combat contre le formica pro
km 190
le spitfire fut l'un des grands amis la
guerre
il
lorsque l'angleterre entre en guerre en
1939 le plus important chasseur de l'air
af était de loin le week-end qui équipe
et dj squadron
équipé d'un moteur mère l'a similaire à
celui du spitfire il était plus gros est
globalement d'une conception plus
ancienne mais leur qualité archives
vraiment simple et facile à entretenir
et réparer
piloter avec beaucoup d'agressivité à un
week-end tout espérer gagner ce combat
en dépit de sa relative lenteur
ici en 1942 des chasseurs bombardiers
marque 2b décollent chaque est important
de banques de 250 lire et pas moins de
douze mitrailleuse 0,303 dans les airs
léa ribambelle entre temps d'action avec
le squad 607 octobre 41 et sur les
premiers chasseurs de l'air af attaqué
avec des bombes
le week-end marque de service sur la
plupart des fonds de la guerre mais
beaucoup furent progressivement
transférés en asie à total de quatorze
mille deux cent trente et un week-end de
toute version fut construit en
angleterre et au canada
ici des travailleurs locaux et dans
l'assemblage d'un briquet dans le port
d'afrique de l'ouest de takoradi prêt
pour le très long vol de livraison dans
la zone de combat du désert
une fois encore ben d'afrique du nord
les conditions rondelle a dit qu aux
avions et aux équipages les a revendu le
plus profond était soudainement
interrompu par leur de décoller
chaque avion effectués parfois plusieurs
décollage chaque jour sous le vent à
nuages de sable mais les filtres sous
les moteurs leur permettait de continuer
à tourner
une version qui fut utilisée le plus
intensivement du sud afrique du nord je
le barc 2d ont-ils tant qu'armée de deux
cadres 48 mètres sous les airs
en birmanie les unités des rêves se
prépare pour une autre nous la mission
outre l'armée japonaise 5,44 eu des bus
les munitions de calibre 0,303 sont
chargées les banques de 250 livres sont
installés sous les ailes et armés les
pilotes ont été briefés
sur le front asiatique l'écho car de
l'air a effectué seulement bleu et blanc
et tous ceux qui comportait un fond
rouge se fait mitrailler
la suprématie aérienne était très
disputée les unités terrestres de l'air
à être était souvent appelée camp
protégés les aérodromes de première
ligne avec des canons beaufort et autres
mitrailleuses
air liquide mark ii b avait 12
mitrailleuses de 0,303 au fil de leurs
charges de mots
l'émission contre un adversaire qui se
fondait dans la jungle était
particulièrement difficile et sur un tel
terrain déterminer l'efficacité de la
mission était toujours problématique
en 1940 le chasseur américain le plus
important qu'est le coeur qui se moquent
75 les premières versions en service
dans les rêves étaient appelés tomahawk
mais ceux ci sont dépités aux trois et
deux des quatre ans 50e et 260e squadron
avec des entrées d'air plus importantes
sur les moteurs
le 260e squadron servait aux côtés du
450e en afrique du nord agathe zalaé
marque urba en egypte en novembre 1942
il n'était pas forcément capable de
dominer mais sur huit bf 119 et
shockwave 190 mêlée qui tirent eux ont
effectué des milliers de missions en
portant d'une bombe de 500 livres sous
le fuselage ait eu deux ententes sur les
facs m
portant les lettres cvc quitté au son du
troisième squadron de la royal
australian air force lequel le 1er
janvier 1942 devint le premier à
employer les kits égaux dans le désert
à l'époque où cette unité fut filmé en
train de décoller poirette pourpre leur
fait accord formel et il était le plus
expérimenté des squadron de chasseurs
bombardiers de tous
une autre unité est très le 112e
squadron de la ras dans les avions
portaient des gueules dure qu'un épi à
la fin à 42 partager son aérodrome avec
les 260e squadron
pour éviter les accidents roulage il
était utile qu'à mécano fais tienne à 6
sur l'ale pour prévenir le pilote de la
proximité des autres avions des
véhicules et même des cratères de bombes
au décollage le train d'atterrissage se
rétracte vers l'arrière les roues pivote
pour s'intégrer dans les ailes
tous les avions de ces escadrons avait
six mitrailleuses de 12,7 dans les ailes
chacune avec 280 une cartouche
bien sûr le p 48 aussi employé par l' us
army air force ces exemplaires sont dp
40-f équipés par des moteurs merlin
construit par packard lesquels ne
possédait plus l'entraidé au dessus du
système de refroidissement
comme tous les autres modèles l'armement
était de six mitrailleuses plus jusqu'à
700 livres de bombes
la rff n'ont reçu que quelques petites
inox à moteur merlin la majorité d'entre
eux allant à l'aviation américaine à
l'union soviétique ou à la france libre
l' us army air force entre en guerre en
afrique du nord par une débarquement de
novembre 1942 ces avions portait une
cocarde entouré de jaune comme pour les
anglais au tour des internationaux et
dans de nombreux cas à drapeau sur la
dérive
chaque squadron trace à la route de la
tunisie et la sicile pour finalement
remonter toute l'italie gagnant une
précieuse expérience
quelques unités du théâtre d'opérations
chine birmanie inde ne portait pas
seulement la gueule de requin sur le nez
mais adopte également la tête de maure
souriante comme cette unité du 80ème
fighter groupe
en tout treize mille sept cent trente
huit exemplaires du cac 40 sur produits
bien évidemment la guerre aérienne à le
pacifique ne fut pas seulement conduite
depuis l'aérodrome terrestre mais
également depuis les minuscules émouvant
pont des porte-avions de l'us navy qui
emportait beaucoup d'appareils conçus
pour des missions spécifiques
un des plus formidables des appareils
fait de bombardiers en piqué douglas sbd
d'anglès conçu par l'ingénieur écouter
est jean heyman le sb d envoyer par le
fond pu les navires japonais que
n'importe quel autre art alliés
avec un moteur ride cyclone de 1200
chevaux et 8 s maximum de 400 kilomètres
heure le club bd pouvaient emporter une
charge de gondeville livre à une
distance de plus de 11 100 km
l'escort été fournies par les chasseurs
de la marine
et
arrivé sur sa cible le dans 13 plaqués
sa charge contre l'ennemi les 2,8 rising
6 permettait également d'anglès de
mitrailler les cibles avec une bonne
efficacité
la localisation du porte-avions était
souvent très difficiles et demandaient
une grande compétence en matière de
navigation
le change à hôtesses 4 corsair est
largement considéré comme le meilleur de
tous les avions à moteur à pistons de
toute la guerre
sa puissance est et cède à pratt &
whitney de 2000 chevaux double au wat
qui entraînait une hélice immense
les ailes repliables contenait les six
mitrailleuses de 12 7 remplacé sur
certaines versions par quatre canons de
20 mm à partir de top 10 143 un
réservoir largable du round 2 178 cas
l'on pouvait être emporté sous le
fuselage et le s4 eu un des pouvaient
emporter également de bons 2000 livres à
ce même endroit
malgré sa grande taille et sa masse le
s4 foot en chasseur particulièrement
brillant et très efficace contre les 1,6
m 0 et tous les autres avions japonais
le premier utilisateur des premières
versions du corsaire jeu l'escadrille
des us navy vs blues qui essuyait les
plâtres de la difficulté à faire
apponter le corsaire sur un porte-avions
ce n'était jamais facile et en 1942 1943
le corsair ne fut pas utilisé par la
navy mais par le corps des marines qui
opérait à partir de l'ong peace parfois
directement sur du corail
ces unités se trouvait à guam ou sur
l'île du roi est alors qu'à la guerre
progressait vers le japon les marines
connurent de plus en plus d'opérations
ici des corsaires des marines effectué
les attaques en piqué à travers un peu
nourri de décès
le curtis sp2c est divers fut produits
en grande quantité il était prévu de
remplacer le s bd comme bombardiers en
piqué standards du lieu est évident mais
il fut modifié sans arrêt et ne donnera
jamais entière satisfaction il ne faut
donc jamais aussi populaire que son
prédécesseur
cependant en 1944 le premier d'entre eux
pulvérisé les forces japonaises à coups
de bombes de 1000 livres et même avec
lequel on va mm
le moteur était à wright cyclone de plus
de 1900 chevaux et sa fiabilité
permettait à beaucoup de sp2c de revenir
à ponte
les équipages avait remplacé la
désignation officielle par celle de sun
beach seconde classe
les années n'aurait pas pu combattre au
dessus de la mer son groupe ce chasseur
de la fleet est rarement aurait dû
s'appeler le gannett mais l'amirauté
décida de conserver son duo américain de
l4d signé f6 f ce superbe chasseurs
posséder le même moteur en doute les
toiles de 2000 chevaux que l'efs cas
plus corsair son rival
de la même façon le train d'atterrissage
se rétracter vers l'arrière et les elle
abrite également 6 me creuse brandi
globus aide dans la plupart des versions
une charge de me livre de bons pouvait
être accrochées sous le fuselage et les
ailes pouvait recevoir six roquettes
les énormes elle rectangulaire de deir
el cata rayon de virages très court et
sa maniabilité était légendaire
le snav y employer les f10 avec des
réservoirs largable depuis les portes à
vire aussi connu que lui ss saratoga
un autre appareil important sortie des
îles brauman fut le tpf avenger
avec softcity 2007 son cheveu sur
triplace rempl salle était vide et
dévastateurs comme bombardier un
torpilleur principal de l'us navy
sa toile dorsale équipés de
mitrailleuses de 12,7 et est motorisé
une autre mitraillage de 7,65 pouvait
tirer vers le bas et vers l'arrière
juste derrière la soute abondent
cette dernière pouvait recevoir une
torpille ou 2000 livres de bord et avec
cette charge sur l'autonomie rester
supérieure à 1600 km
ici en 1944 et et bf était escorté par
des f 6 f l cat munis de réservoir
largable le pacifique du souhait ce
n'était pas l'endroit idéal pour un
atterrissage forcé
en
1944 et émergent comme la fqcf pouvez
reporter des roquettes de saint kitts
après chaque mission il fallait
toutefois effectué un retour brutal sur
le pont toujours mouvant du porte-avions
mais les produits grumman avait une
telle réputation de solidité qu'on les
appelait les enchères d'acier de grumman
on ne pouvait consomme 2 p 38 lightning
avec aucun autre appareil ces moteurs
était d alison 2002 125 chevaux installé
au bout de longues poutres qui
supportaient les dérives
ces poutres se met également le train
d'atterrissage en dessous les
compresseurs du moteur sur le dessus et
les radiateurs sur chaque côté derrière
l'est
le pilote les armes et le train avant se
trouvait dans une petite nacelle
centrale l'armement standard comportait
un canon de 20 mm cadre mitrailleuses de
12,7
de bondeville livre de grands réservoirs
supplémentaires devaient être suspendues
sous les ailes les versions les plus
tarder y avait une capacité de 1600 lieu
jusqu'à dire ok
sur le terre du pacifique les p 38
revendiquèrent plus d'avions japonais
que n'importe quel autre appareil de
l'air fort le grand âge de la chasse
abritait de toute la guerre le bdj
richard baum obtint toutes ces 40
victoires à bord d'un pétrolier dans le
pacifique dans cette guerre difficile
qu'ils allaient d'îles en îles
non
le béton tu dois également rôle
important sur le front européen les
allemands le surnommèrent darga belle
chante store iphone le démon en
accrochant au dessus des champs verts de
l'angleterre des centaines de laïcs il
décollait chaque jour pour escorter les
bombardiers nommé 17 et b 24 de la
huitième heure force
de ces missions ils rapportaient des
films montant qu'ils pouvaient tenir la
dragée haute aux agf w190 aussi bien
qu'aux modèles sur chenilles 109
en 1944 d'autres p38 emporté des
requêtes effectuer des missions
d'attaqué au sol dans tout le nord de
l'europe
ces missions demandé également parfois
on utilise les rockets de saint kitts en
salles contre les cibles terrestres
les p38 et n'est pas les seuls à assurer
les scores des bombardiers et chacune de
ses missions était précédé par un
briefing complet comme on le voit ici
c'est
resté dehors
explique le sexe l'âge ou d'extrême
gauche aux
sports
parce que l'autonomie des chasseurs
était limite équipes ne pouvaient pas
escortés des bombardiers tout au long de
leur route à l'aller comme au retour des
reliques chasseurs étaient organisées
avec des points de rendez vous le long
du terrain
est radin seulement permettait à
l'ennemi d'être avertis des raids et lui
donner la possibilité de masse et ses
chasseurs pour se défendre
le partenaire du p 38 dans son défi face
aux chasseurs allemands étaient le
république paie 40 700 demandes
ce chasseur était si gros et si costaud
qu'il fut rapidement surnommé le jag le
tonneau
le moteur est emprunté 8 r 2800 reggae
de 2000 à 2008 100 chevaux renforcée par
un turbocompresseur sous l'arrière du
fuselage
donc cnc lipstick inspiré du spitfire se
trouvait un armement dévastateur de 8000
13 12 7 mm
les premiers modèles les p 47 des
détections de virus au bac en raison de
la redd qui court du top 8 à la dérive
le pied 47 eu le monomoteur le plus long
entre en service pendant la guerre la
version finale ne p 47 aides faisait pas
ce que dit c'est à dire le poids de deux
bombardiers les naïm celui de cartes
spitfire m41
en dépit de sa taille il pouvait être un
redoutable chasseur en particulier avec
la version des 47 10 25 son entrée au
service avec une guerrière aux gouttes
d'eau sens montant
lors d'une mission des scores d'escadre
il argué les réservoirs supplémentaires
dès les premiers signes de présence de
chasseurs et amis et lors du combat qui
s'ensuivait descendants ball faisait
honneur à leur réputation
un des chasseurs alliés les plus récents
conçu après le début des hostilités le p
51 mustang fut créée pour les anglais un
superbe appareil conçu pour être équipés
des nouvelles ailes laminaire et d'une
entrée d'air du radiateur sous le
fuselage est très réduite
le mustang a commencé sa carrière avec
un moteur allison 2000 150 chevaux
à basse altitude il était plus rapide
que le speed file bien qu il transporta
plus du double de carburant que celui ci
l'armement comprenait quatre
mitrailleuses 7 65 mm et deux de 12 7 mm
dans les ailes et deux de 12,7 sur le
moteur dans les missions d'attaqué au
sol ils étaient réellement formidable il
était capable de larguer les premières
bombes au napalm
le mustang s'avéra si bon qu'il fut
rapidement adopté par l'aviation
américaine
le à 36 à invaders d' attaque au sol
entre en action sicile en 1943
sur les aérodromes de fond sicilien le
carburant est délivré en baril qui
devait être vidé laborieusement dans les
réservoirs de cinq appareils
où
tous deux bombes de 500 livres pouvaient
être emporté sous les ailes sur ces
images les armuriers installé bon et
recharger mitrailleuse sur le à 36 4
mitrailleuses 12 7 étaient installés
dans les ailes et 2 7 65 mm dans le nez
il avait des aérofreins de piquer mais
qui furent letra lisez par la suite
l'émission au départ de la piscine avait
pour objectif de patrouiller ou dessus
du détroit de messine en italie
oh
bon
north american construisit cinq cents à
36 ha il n'imaginait pas encore qu'elle
produirait pour la version américains
plus de 13500 appareils de la version de
chasse baptisé p-51
le tournant d'origine la ras reçu plus
de 600 appareils équipés de moteurs à
lui seul un modèle le aaa étaient armés
de canons de 20 mm
il servir avec le commandement de
coopération avec l'armée et en octobre
42 ils devinrent les premiers chasseurs
anglais a pénétré dans l'espace aérien
allemand lors de missions contre le
canal james à dortmund
en 1944 la version améliorée avec un
moteur berlin arrivé en service avec une
importante augmentation de vitesse et de
plafonds
seul 84 avec la verrière ambühl avait
été testé par la ras à boscombe down
rs reçu plus de 1800 mustang à moteur
berlin mais le plus gros utilisateur fut
la us army air force qui l'employait sur
tous les fronts
le groupe des pionniers du nist ans
après eux mêmes étaient le 354e groupe
de la neuvième et air force qui a reçu
ces mustang berlin à la fin de 43
ici ce groupe parade avec cp 51 qui
n'ont pas été peint en juin 44 qu'il
quitte à l'angleterre pour la france et
signant la guerre basé en allemagne
armé de six mitrailleuses 12 7 mm les p
51d ont dominé le ciel jusqu'à prague et
berlin
le maréchal goering celle de la houppe
fois feu déclara lorsque j'ai vu c'est
lui sans doute super l'un j'ai su que la
guerre était perdue
bien sûr le plus grand et le plus
monstrueux qu'on fuit se dérouler sur le
fond est ici des yaks 9la régiment de la
garde se prépare à affronter la
luftwaffe en 43 comme les autres
chasseurs soviétiques l'oiac 9 avait un
moteur puissant sur une cellule légère
avec un armement léger généralement un
canon de 20 mm et deux mitrailleuses 12
les chasseurs soviétiques étaient
conçues pour les plus hautes
performances et la meilleure maniabilité
le yak 9 par exemple était équipée d'un
moteur klimov un refroidissement liquide
2260 chevaux
malheureusement navigation ce biais
qu'il souffrait de la mauvaise
maintenance effectués par des
mécaniciens mal formés et qu'ils avaient
un travailleur des cours sur
l'incroyable midi
ici le nombre d'appareils et
principalement des yaks 1 7 et 9 ou gage
l'ennemi
quand la rs envoyé à 550 kms cadres dans
des cendres normaux ce qu'en 1941 et
surtout impressionné de prouver des
bombardiers soviétique qu'ils avaient du
mal à suivre il s'agissait des pets la
coff pe2 qu'on peut décrire comme
globalement des mosquito tri place avec
deux dérives c'est brillant bombardiers
tactiques équipé de deux moteurs vk sens
un ps de 1260 chevaux pouvait atteindre
540 km ha en panier et s'il voulait
réellement plein gaz comme les pilotes
politiques allaient tendance à le faire
il aurait sans doute celui des scores de
la huitaine
la charge de bombe était de 1200 clients
dans la soupe centrale et les nacelles
moteurs ainsi que sous 4 point d'emport
sous les ailes
l'inversion de chasse le pe trois
avaient des volets de combat la place
des offres un piquet et posséder un
canon de 20 mm et une mitrailleuse 12,7
en plus
ces missions furent effectués pendant la
campagne de reconquête de sébastopol en
crimée en avril 1944
quelques pylônes de est encore dans leur
camouflage hivernale
les scop elle comprenait d y accéder
prédécesseur duilhac 9
au total onze 1427 pe2 se reconstruit
de tous les avions d'histoire celui qui
était produit en plus grand nombre
étaient signés chine et l 2 sturmovik
le total atteint un chiffre astronomique
de 3,6 1136
et staline déclara l'armée rouge a
besoin de lier deux comme elle a besoin
d'air et de pain
fait lourdement bien dit que n'importe
quel autre avion sa mission était de
survoler les sources d'un nationale
mandaté basse altitude et de l'écrire
les chars des division de panzers on ne
pouvait imaginer des missions plus
dangereux
au début en dépit de son blindage il
s'avéra vulnérables face aux chasseurs
de la luftwaffe
on lui ajoute a donc un mitrailleur
tourner vers l'arrière 1 et mx 1 jauzion
qui lui sert pour détruire les blindés
allemands le sturmovik pouvait utiliser
des bons des cadeaux des armes
expérimenté par l'union soviétique des
années 30 comme des rockets
de loin la roquette plus utilisés tels
ars 82 d'un calibre de 82 mm au départ
six roquettes pouvait être installé puis
8 et vers 1944 de meilleures
installations permettait d'en porter 30
mais elles peuvent supporter jusqu'à 400
kilos de bombes mais la charge la plus
efficace était constituée de 200 grenade
anti tente
mais peut-être plus utiliser toutes ses
armes c'était le calme
au départ les âmes les plus puissantes
et unique adresse h 20 à 80 mm mais ils
ont été changés pour les perdants mais
pas de vente par le mur est encore plus
efficace
en 1944 de nombreux m2 m3 et reçu les
normes aîné sokka b16 de prendre 7 mm
qui peut et transpercer le blindage de
chartis
une des méthodes d' attaques les plus
courants qui était de former un cercle
au dessus des tentes chaque avion
effectués dans celui qu une attaque en
piqué rejoignant toute information ceci
rend des métros et des chasseurs de la
luftwaffe assez difficile les équipages
des chars allemands appeler cela le
cercle de la mort
le
l'équivalent du sturmovik de la rs était
le rockeur qui foulent
conscientisation 38 comme chasseur pour
remplacer le riz khan il était très
puissant et se magner bien
l'armement était de 4 canons hispano de
20 mm et de deux bombes de 1000 livres
plus tard on installe à huit roquettes
faisant de ces attaques de véritables
bord des deux navires de combat
son moteur n'a pierce à 2200 chevaux il
était vraiment bon tapas altitude le
typhon ont failli être annulée mais 3270
sur finalement construit et employés
pour la console
ici ce sont des petits fous un b du 174
le squadron de la ras opérationnel alors
bondi à l'été 1944
l'édifice jouent un rôle décisif dans
les combats épiques qui suivit un
débarquement allié du 6 juin 44
il saute employait la destruction des
lignes d'approvisionnement et de
communication allemande attaquant tout
ce qui bougeait et bien plus encore sur
les routes gérées voie ferrée du nord de
la france
les typhoons intervenez comme à retirer
aérienne et rocket de 6 kg et dépasser
1000 kilomètres heure
en août 1944 et un ciel corps américain
et la première armée canadienne
commencèrent leur manoeuvre pour
s'emparer 2002 pallez et encerclé le
groupe b de l'armée allemand
mais qui foulent surpris la 2e division
de panzers de la ss se dépassant deux
jours et là des six maires
alors que les allemands se précipiter
pour s'échapper par la percée au
nord-est de falaise l'équipe ou leur
tomber dessus à coup de canon de
roquettes et de bombes
les appareils alliés détruisirent 5000
véhicules offrent à jo l'été foule
s'adjuge 11 175 chiens en une seule
journée
les routes étaient littéralement congrès
d'épaves incendié deux blindés de
camions et d'artillerie
en 1944 et empestent était également
service le temps de paix c'était à la
base hâtif ou avec une aile elliptique
piscine avec un réservoir de carburant
supplémentaire un fuselage rallonger
les temps peste 5 le premier entre en
service était un super puma sion
bombardier
il te met opérationnel en quantité juste
à temps pour se joindre au foot au
dessus de la france et au nord de
l'europe à l'été 44
le temple est arrivé juste à temps pour
contrer la nouvelle arme allemande la b1
surnommé le donald bug ou le plongeur
par la défense aérienne anglaise
ces puissants missiles de croisière
était pointée par centaines vers londres
et se présentaient comme des petites
cibles très rapide
il était particulièrement difficile a
touché mêlée ce cadre basé à new york et
qui opérait au dessus de la région
côtière du kent réussi à descendre pas
moins de 6 ans 38 c bon volant beaucoup
plus que n'importe quel autre unité
trois autres v1 furent descendus par le
gloucester météores bi moteur à réaction
du 600 16e squadron de la
rfl eu deux versions du météore le mark
1 avec des réacteurs rolls royce
weylandt et une verrière basculante et
le mar 3 avec des réacteurs d'héroïne et
une verrière coulissantes
conçu pour remporter six canons le
météore entre en opération avec quatre
canons hispano montées sur les côtés
d'une et
la fiabilité ces cas n'ont plus jamais
très satisfaisant
d'ailleurs lors de la première
interception d'une bon volant les canons
sans reyer mais le pilote fait basculer
le v1 avec le groupe selon elle
la chasse aux vins par les météores
furent les premiers combats j'aide
contre hudgens
au niveau de la mer les premiers jets
opérationnelle des alliés dépassé de
plus de 100 km la vitesse des chasseurs
un moteur à pistons
de tous les chasseurs vallier affiche
une masse de 17 tonnes n'offre au pis 61
black widow fut aussi le seul aviron
alliés conçu dès le départ comme un
chasseur de nuit
mus par deux pratt & whitney air 2008 en
étoile de 2000 chevaux il avait un
équipage de trois ans pour piloter
l'appareil s'occuper de radars ont
utilisé les 4 80 mm
dans la plupart des cas l'équipage avait
aussi à gérer les 4 victorieuse de
celles qui se trouvaient dans la
tourelle dorsale motorisés la plupart
des black widow apatrides en pacifique
mais c'est p 61 porte des bandes de
débarquement pour le théâtre
d'opérations européen ils servent 422e
et 425e fighter squadron
en europe et black widow trouvèrent
toulouse craf assez insaisissable mais
ils furent crédité de 9 rebonds
violentes et de nombreux autres
appareils de lax
le principal chasseur denis d'angleterre
fut le magnifique des highland mosquito
construit en bois dutil de rolls royce
merlin les versions des chasse de nuit
pilote un opérateur radar assis côte à
côte dans le cockpit en dépit du large
cockpit la vitesse maximum dépasser
largement 640 km 1 en moyenne altitude
la plupart des versions avec une porte
juste derrière le cockpit mais sur les
versions chasse équipé de quatre canaux
soulevant la porte qui est située sur le
côté droit
chaque canon disposer d'un mix de 150
buts 20 mm
l'injection le plus nombreuse était le
chasseur bombardier marc 6 dans le nez à
la place du radar cette version disposer
de quatre vitrines brisées au 303 ainsi
que des cadeaux entre
il emporter jusqu'à me livre de beaumont
sud et deux bombes de 500 lits lui vos
questions les ailes
c'est marchi du 20e squadron partent
pour une des nombreuses missions
spéciales encore par les unités de
moscato
des couleurs avec eux un bombardier marc
cattani vitré il s'agit d'une des z 414
qui servent avions photos sur cette
sortie une des plus impressionnantes
attaques de tous les temps
en effet en février 1944 quelques 700
résistants étaient détenus par les
allemands dans la prison d'amiens et
nombre d'entre eux attendent leur
exécution par la gestapo
l'aref s'était donné l'objectif est
incroyable de les sortir de là avec un
vague de bombardements une précision
incroyable en termes 2-2 tu as aimé
et l'espagne 21 464 487 fournir chacun
six de leurs équipages des plus
expérimentés les mosquito été escortés
par des tahitiens du stade route 198 le
plan consistait à confier aux trois
premiers avions de 485,5 squadron ne
sont en attaque le muret sq de la prison
tandis que les trois avions suivant
attaqué le bureau nord
au même instant trois avions dû 400 64e
détruire les quartiers des gars de nazis
à l'est de la prison tandis que trois
appareils du même escadron s'en
prendrait aux bâtiments des garde situé
à l'est
si l'attaqué choux et les six avions dû
xxième squadron ii avaient attaqué la
prison directement dans l'espoir que
quelques prisonniers pourrait s'échapper
les mots ce qui te tue cher la prison
comme prévu larguant leur bova 15 pieds
et grimpant pour éviter les bâtiments
dans les ralentis on peut voir que les
bombes tombent au bon endroit comme si
on les avait posé la main sur les murs
les baraques des gardes allemands
en quelques minutes 258 prisonniers se
sont échappés parmi eux 12 qui devait
être fusillé le lendemain le 21 mars
1945 les mêmes squadron 21 noeuds 464 et
le 487 su remobiliser pour une autre
attaque de précisions cette fois pour
que l'immeuble à la hausse à copenhague
au la gestapo avait son quartier général
après un vol de deux heures au dessus de
la mer du nord les avions attaqué les
mots ce qui tout survolèrent les trois
lacs au centre de la ville et
basculèrent sur la gauche au dessus de
d'orvault gamme
en continuant à tourner à gauche il
survolait un autre lac avant de se
retrouver aligné sur la cime chaque
groupe de mosquito veille les bords du
groupe précédent tomber sur l'immeuble
généralement par les fenêtres des
premier et second étages
l'immeuble était sévèrement de magie de
même que les dossiers concernant les
résistants
malheureusement un mosquito s'écrasa sur
une école après avoir touché un
lampadaire et la troisième vague rata sa
cible par erreur
le mosquito rentrés à leur base altitude
le partenaire du mosquito fait le 12
tombo facteurs une machine puissante et
solide comme un croiseur est doté de
deux moteurs 10 tolère que le mic 600
chômeurs
le bout fighter commença sa carrière
comme chasseur de nuit mais rapidement
fut transformé en navire d'assaut y
compris avec des roquettes de syndic aux
commandes tandis que d'autres ont porté
des temples
ces appareils à partir de 489 baden de
la royal new zealand air force et ont
servi dans une escarmouche d'un tacle
tiers à partir de la base de balle ce en
écosse
leurs ornements standard comprenait
quatre canaux hispano de 20 mm et six
mitrailleuses des caïds 03 centre
une vickers simple et inégalement
installés dans le poste de tir dorsale
à la place de la torpille 2656 vous des
2 milliards de bons les bords d'attaqué
cloutier remporté huit roquettes sous
les eaux
quelles que soient les armes emporté en
externe les beaux fighter pour voler à
480 km heure et conserver une excellente
maniabilité
ici nous assistons à raid contre des
navires dans les eaux norvégiennes un
organe le 5 décembre 44 le travail
partagé entre les mosquitos is du 248e
squadron une autre unité de la cms cadre
d' attaques de base
on
le mosquito l'hebdo fighter furent
utilisés largement au long des missions
de trois ou quatre heures parfois suivis
de combats intenses
il devait d'éviter la flac il devait
d'éviter les montagnes et les parois des
fjords
il est difficile de trouver les mots
pour décrire l'intensité des attaques au
canon et à la roquette
oui
la guinée
m
il
moi
le travail de ces chasseurs et chasseurs
bombardiers alliés pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale s'est étendue à tous les
fronts à toutes les altitudes par
n'importe quel temps avec tout les sens
d'armement
ils ont apporté la victoire aux alliés